are you an anxious person
super anxious me too yeah
so if you're anxious it's like Who's
Gonna Save this when it's sinking do you
want an anxious pilot no no meet Sam
whose current job as a Lyft driver feels
weird in your back oh he's so cute
so cute oh yeah no
no Sam's date is Rachel a medical
professional it's not gonna work
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way and
let's get started so today I am going to
be reacting to anxious daters hit it off
on the first date no no welcome
appreciate it oh he's so cute how you
doing welcome appreciate it he doesn't
look anxious meet Sam whose current job
as a Lyft driver feels weird in your
back is the result of his life taking
some unexpected turns I worked for the
government for six years you know I went
from like 85k and great benefits to you
know um you know changing my career
around uh sharp suit thank you you know
what I was thinking I thought thought he
would do so well but when he started
talking it's like I could hear the
femininity in his voice right I was like
oh he's handsome why is he nervous but I
came back to school and I'm in a
copywriting school you know so I'm kind
of all over the place how's your day
going not bad man that's chilling all
right yeah he's chilling yeah just
chilling I couldn't really do much you
know I had to had to prep up you know
yeah I got the shave going man he's
still cute though he's so cute it's an
awkward situation you know I walk in
um I drive a lift who throws in I drive
lift as like a
a humble brag like you guys ever heard
of it it's not Uber it's Lyft
I wonder why he quit the 80k year job I
don't think you guessed it it's funny
for someone with a lot of anxiety I come
off as a very confident person but like
everybody you know insecure uh you know
at times you know nobody wants to get
rejected
[Music]
it's not gonna work a medical
professional with a Lyft driver she's
cute too whose life doesn't quite fit
into the age of instant everything I'm
kind of a grandma I feel like I live
life kind of in a slower pace
then everyone around me I go to bed
early if I can Hi how are you good how
are you welcome good thanks you know you
see those old couples and they're so
cute and they're holding hands and the
guy is like pulling out the chair
whoever that guy is as a younger person
is what I'm looking for not like
Benjamin Button trapped in a smaller pot
sometimes when we talk about
relationships it just sounds like fairy
tale but
you know just someone who has a good
Soul where's the grandpa where are they
where are they in your friend zone also
I think so she said the guy those old
couples the guy that pulls out the chair
does all of that I think women actually
believe that when they see an old copper
and they see the man doing all of these
things they actually believe that the
man did all of that for all the years he
was with that woman yeah only God knows
the kind of things that woman went
through with that guy yeah yeah that's
true that's true well and it's like like
people especially in our generation we
have to learn to be husbands and wives
like most of us didn't see that growing
up
um and even if like most people did it's
still the woman like most people haven't
seen traditional relationships so
something we got to learn um but a lot
of times we expect Perfection hello
hello let me introduce you Paul how are
you doing nice to meet you nice to meet
you good what's your name my name is Sam
Sam Rachel Rachel pleasure yeah are you
nervous at all yes yeah oh he didn't
pull out the chair dang it but it's cool
it's exciting yeah do you live in
Chicago I do I live in Wrigleyville okay
cool yeah I actually just moved here I
was in DC for the last seven years oh
really I'm like the Benjamin Button of
careers
[Laughter]
well I'm trying to you know I work for
the government for six years just gonna
go back to preschool soon
I had my mom nurse me
so it's really hard to find a guy who's
a mix of adventurous and lazy
I think that's a good mix honestly it's
like it's we want men that don't exist
it's like do you want adventurous or do
you want you want lazy like what's your
well your table is ready
don't use that
that was a train of thought that
shouldn't have happened
well I steak and crab for two
but I'm allergic to crap you're allergic
to crap I don't know
when I go on first dates uh I have a
very big personality uh in terms of
joking sometimes that person either
doesn't get it or I do it a little too
much and it is a weird situation so what
do you do for fun last year and this
year I biked 40 miles round trip to the
Chicago Botanical Garden wow that's
impressive 40 miles is that like if a
girl said she biked 40 miles to you
would that be a plus she's in shape
right yeah have you been on the
Lakeshore path yeah I live like right
off the path it's super dangerous like
Lance Armstrong everywhere you're just
they're like yelling at you taking kids
out dog running
yeah
yeah the three I put in my van for
dessert no it is really it's really
check please
so what do you uh what do you do
um I work at the Children's Hospital
nice for two cardiologists oh cool yeah
I hate that question what do you do but
uh actually currently I'm a Lyft driver
right now I bet that's really
entertaining
it really is yeah
now I love writing but I'm on
[Music]
divide gravity there now we just got
really awkward
I don't know if this is going well it's
not going horrible I think it's going
okay how do you think it's going yeah
it's like I feel like she's in she
starts to like him but then he says
something kind of awkward and she
questions it one of those ones where
unless he saves it soon she's just gonna
enjoy the date and probably never yeah
yeah but I don't think it's like
completely out yet the same in here
thank you absolutely
are you an anxious person
[Music]
I think as a guy if you're an anxious
person you should keep that to yourself
I'm not gonna lie to you like we don't
where are the anxious ones we're like oh
no this could go wrong this could go you
know why as women we do every day we
just think about things that are gonna
go wrong guys you know as much as we
talk about women being crazy there's a
reason it's like how our brain works you
know what I mean we're just thinking oh
this could go wrong that could go wrong
I think guys would go crazy too if they
had to live life as a woman for one day
so if you're a anxious it's like Who's
Gonna Save this when it's sinking do you
want an anxious pilot no no it's it's
the same thing teachers diagnosed me
with OCD but I refuse to quit I refuse
to believe it I totally repeat it three
times I was like OCD OCD OCD people
think like OCD they think of like
washing your hands but you're like Turn
the Lights which like yeah which I do
but it's more about like the mind
because you're like you're second
guessing stuff you're doubting stuff
um I lost my train of thought
redirect me on the top you you know OCD
do you remember my name Rachel okay
okay do you know what I think I
understand why guys don't get hit I
think I do because as women it's like
we'll be smiling
and they don't understand like the micro
expressions of like we are never gonna
talk to you again or like you will never
speak to this woman again so I
understand why guys get so confused
because we do send a lot of mixed
signals I won't lie to you that was an
aggressive question though if I failed
that answer
well I haven't dated very much I was in
an eight-year relationship we met when I
was 18 so I don't know it's fun to kind
of get to know what it's like all over
again as an adult are you close to your
family your parents yeah yeah totally
okay I have a question king would you
rather date a girl that was in one eight
year relationship three two-year
relationships a one eight year
relationship almost like a marriage an
eight-year relationship like she was
married 30 parents are together they are
that's a weird question so your parents
are together so are your parents
together are yours they are not they got
divorced um I don't know I was really
young yeah I haven't been in many
relationships at all okay a lot of that
was probably like you should keep that
to yourself as a guy yourself you know
I've had a couple that have been like a
few months I haven't had uh many
relationships uh you know last a while I
feel like myself sabotage would be first
date is like a therapy session yeah he's
bringing up his anxiety yeah it's
supposed to be fun you know it's
supposed to be like uh uh I usually run
away when the girl starts to like me
because it's obviously something wrong
with her if she likes me you know
sometimes they have wow he's got to go
to therapy there's a mirror I have been
interested in them but I just haven't
found the the goodness or maybe get some
like guys around him I I could just hear
the lack of like a male presence around
like you can just hear and you could
hear it too in a guy's voice when he
starts to hang out with more men it's
like I don't know what it is you can
just tell